in sunny southern california the sole of
the american solar industry mark smith
can't find solar panels at any price
yesterday we put it in order for solar
panels for the product that we use and
i'm being told august
this is unheard of for my company
so this is really detrimental how long
would it normally take two weeks the u.s
solar power industry has been nearly
frozen in time since late march
that's when the u.s commerce department
started investigating whether china was
evading u.s tariffs by shipping solar
panels through four other countries and
because 80 percent of the panels in the
u.s come from those countries cambodia
malaysia thailand and vietnam almost no
one is buying them they're afraid if
they buy them now later they'll have to
pay stiff retroactive tariffs
and there are few other options we can
almost not tolerate this and survive
many companies will go under
an industry survey found companies are
now considering laying off 38 000
americans more than a third of the solar
workforce and could lose 30 billion
dollars in lost projects the man who
asked for the government probe knows
what his rivals think of his company
most hated solar company in america
mamoon rasheed founder of the tiny
silicon valley panel maker oxen solar
says he's trying to save the u.s solar
industry from chinese domination and
unfair competition if it sticks that
means
a two thing cheating was going on
and number two
it highlights how dependent we are
on foreign suppliers
and we need to
get off of that dependency because these
panels are coming in
lower than our bill of materials
so the us worker hasn't even had a
chance and they've lost the race they
haven't even entered the race something
is very wrong with that the kerfuffle is
undermining president biden's ambitious
goal to have solar make up 40 percent of
the nation's energy use by 2035.
members of congress are furious but
powerless how we shoot ourselves in the
foot by allowing this kind of stuff to
happen the longer the situation persists
the more severe the damage will be the
u.s commerce secretary says the probe
will take as long as it takes my hands
are very tight here i'm required by
statute to investigate a claim that
companies operating in other countries
are trying to circumvent the duties and
i'm required by statute to have a
fulsome investigation
a preliminary ruling is due in august a
final decision could take a year another
trip around the sun that might bring
precious little progress for the
american solar industry john hendren al
jazeera santa monica california